can you cheat in a game before it
releases so picture this you crack a
game and you're able to play it for six
months before it actually releases to
everybody that Head Start might not mean
a lot to me or maybe to you but to a pro
player who's trying to win tournaments
it could be significant at least for
some period of time until people catch
up so is this cheating after six months
of doing nothing Capcom has finally said
yeah it is
[Music]
we're back talking about cheating one of
my favorite topics so if you enjoy the
topic and you're not already subscribed
why not consider it especially if you
like the video if you don't like the
video
okay
no pressure so back in October 2022
there was a closed beta test that only
had eight characters in it and mostly
the people invited were like streamers
Pros personalities people like that so
the reception to the game actually
seemed pretty good especially the net
code which had players really far apart
playing some high quality matches love
to see it however it was played through
Steam and after a certain point the beta
period was supposed to end and it was
supposed to be impossible to launch this
application and play this Street Fighter
6 beta well it ended up getting cracked
and that meant that anyone with the
cracked executable could still play this
version of the beta even after the beta
period had expired so it seems like the
early versions of this executable
actually just bypassed steam but that
was a little uncomfortable for some
people because you still showed up as
playing Street Fighter 6 and presumably
steam could see that too and it seems
like eventually there were versions of
the track that completely bypassed steam
that steam didn't have to be tricked
because basically the application was
just like running on your computer so
before we move on to capcom's words and
potential future actions on this
particular issue I think we should
address an obvious objection here which
is so what so what if some people played
the beta for six months ahead of time
who cares who is that hurting
okay let's talk about that and while I
don't agree with this objection I think
that it's calm enough that we should
talk about it well first off we should
just say there is a lot of money on the
line for Street Fighter 6 this year
there's gonna be a total of two million
dollars with a one million dollar grand
prize offered by Capcom
so if this affected that in really any
way
that's not good and listen I think
having that much time with the video
game does represent an advantage we can
argue about what kind of Advantage
exactly it represents or about how long
it might feasibly last sure I mean it's
hard to know those things but I still
think it does represent an advantage so
like unless they cancel Street Fighter 6
completely and rebuild it from nothing
the people who played this cracked
version were playing some version of the
game that we're going to see in June
others have argued that this opened the
closed beta and somehow democratized it
well I'm sympathetic to the spirit of
the argument I mean Capcom never said
this was okay again it wasn't capcom's
intention to allow this and let's not
forget people actually took measures to
make the game playable when it shouldn't
have been this isn't some freak accident
or fluke they did this intentionally so
here we are the last time I thought
Capcom might actually do something about
this you could just address it I was
trying not to eat my kids Halloween
candy and that's not an exaggeration
fast forward six months and we have the
statement from Capcom that claims quote
this is a violation of the CVT terms of
service and can be seen as a violation
of the Capcom Pro Tour code of conduct
also that candy is
it's gone
it's totally gone and sure this is great
information and I'm happy that Capcom
did address this but it would have been
a lot better to talk about it six months
ago either Capcom never heard about this
issue at any point before now which is
so implausible that I just don't think
it's reasonable to assume that or they
just waited for some reason I don't get
it I honestly don't but I think they
succeeded at that somehow and then they
just brought it back
Capcom continued quote for the clear
avoidance of Doubt from this point
forward any player who is shown with
clear evidence to be accessing the CBT
in an unauthorized way may be deemed
ineligible for the upcoming Capcom Pro
Tour and Street Fighter League Seasons
but this all seems like too little too
late to me I mean people have been
playing it for six months now they're
gonna say everybody stop and promise you
won't do it again and if your judgment
is so poor that you do and we can prove
it then we might ban you Japanese
fighting game promo Mochi apparently
voiced his frustration with the
situation before Capcom issued their
ruling so will anyone actually face
consequences for this my guess is no if
your judgment is so poor that you decide
to continue to access the CBT and to
give people evidence of that fact well I
really doubt anyone's gonna stick up for
you now and you know even though this
statement seems to suggest that this
will only be in force going forward I
have to imagine a lot of YouTube videos
got set to private over the last week
now now lest you think I'm here to
defend Capcom in some way I'm not they
really messed up here by not addressing
it sooner and so in some ways this
problem is of their own making listen
even if Capcom couldn't revoke access
from these cracked betas because they
were no longer working through Steam or
whatever
even just saying don't do this it is
considered a violation and if we catch
you you will be punished would have
deterred some people from getting
involved in this thing in the first
place or maybe you just give the beta to
everyone a radical solution maybe but
one that would have made the community a
lot happier honestly this really worries
me as somebody who played Street Fighter
2 basically religiously I want to live
to see a street fighter 7 and a street
fighter 8. but this is not the way to
get there Street Fighter 6 has a massive
potential for not just the series but
for fighting games as a whole and we
know this because it's happened before
Street Fighter 4's 2009 launch
revitalized what seemed like a doom
genre and brought in a new generation of
players to bring fighting games into the
decades to come and then Street Fighter
5's rough launch hampered it for a while
and even though the game has gotten to a
really good place and one that many
people consider to be a very good
competitive fighting game
it wasn't good for a while and Tekken
took advantage of that to earn some much
needed territory and Spotlight in the
fgc things are more complicated than
ever for Capcom they're balancing a lot
of stuff and I'm not going to say that
they aren't because you know leverless
controllers like the hitbox have become
issues the net play problem and the need
for extremely high quality net play is
also a concern and now you've got stuff
like this where applications are being
cracked betas are being extended for
indefinite periods of time and Capcom
just has to deal with that but if they
want to give their game the best chance
to succeed
I think they have to be more proactive
about things like this
make sure you're getting enough light
I'm not getting enough light and on days
where I have to film in the morning and
I have like soft boxes on in here and I
just accidentally leave them on
I feel like a I feel like a God I feel
like a deity like I have so much energy
but if I sit in this dark basement
without that it's horrible